[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute parti pour
changer se sortir ici on parle de cul
[Applaudissements]
trente nageurs
jamais jamais jamais tu as vu ce qui se
passe là tout le monde quoi tu me parles
tu rigoles ou quoi la radio ou la télé
journaux tout le monde en face à l'autre
et oui ce matin je suis allé au pressing
m'attends à tout florian parler aussi
bien sinon par louis lui aussi passifs
ils en parlent ça veut dire que tout le
monde
un milicien du soir bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission pas comme les autres vous
connaissez le principe tout le monde en
parle alors tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez les clips ainsi dans ma
vie
[Applaudissements]
à
alors mesdames messieurs laurent en
dehors de l'amitié que j'ai pour vous
laurent la raison de votre présence ici
ce soir c'est le nombre d'e-mails que
j'ai reçus pendant la semaine vous
concernant c'est à dire que les gens me
disent il est formidable il faut
absolument qu'ils reviennent toutes les
semaines je dois revenir cette semaine
on verra parce qu'en fait c'est le
public qui fait les miss c'est
formidable de redécouvrir les gens bravo
oui dix ans après alors mise à part
laurent baffie je recevrai ce soir
bernard tapie sarah marshall
[Applaudissements]
christine angot
oscar à
michel boujenah
et
elle était
à
[Musique]
et oui depuis cinq semaines depuis cinq
semaines il a planté toutes les stars de
cette émission
d'ailleurs j'en reçois beaucoup du mail
pour lui aussi nicole kaczmarek me dis
je vais savoir si tu es certain qu'il
n'ya rien entre ta femme c'est ma femme
qui s'occupe de la musique dans
l'émission donc du blind test et mickaël
arcadia me dit tu compte le garder
combien de temps va nitia me dis quand
est-ce que tu t'en débarrasse bon et ça
y est alors il ya un mec qui dit tu
devrais lui faire un blindtest façon pop
anglaise de la fin des années 60 parce
qu'il connaît que le top 50 ce gars là
alors c'est nickel ça va parce que parce
qu'en fait la vérité c'est qu'au début
il amusé et mademoiselle et chez tout le
monde
non c'est pas ça c'est pas ça c'est que
moi michael je lui demande chaque
semaine de se déguiser et les gens
croient qu'ils se la pète
donc ils se disent c'est pas cela dit a
vu là sa loge ouais ils ont agrandi la
porte
alors on vire et michael car telle est
notre objectif pour bien et mickaël
héliporté
[Applaudissements]
les deux portiers
je les vois les mois
pas de bras
pokora alors ses pairs
l e
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute quartier voilà
donc vous saurez le résultat à la fin de
l'émission dans le fameux blindtest faut
dire quand même nos amis téléspectateurs
que cortier appelle mon épouse depuis ce
matin pour avoir le blind test et qu'il
n'a jamais eu les réponses quand même je
tiens à le dire c'est pas comme kad et
olivier avec linda hardy s'est cette
fois c'est très très sérieux alors vous
savez laurent qui est une tradition dans
cette émission c'est que chaque semaine
on regarde les meilleurs moments c'est
vrai de l'émission précédente et je
crois que vous allez vous voir beaucoup
la manigance et je veux pas que ça
manque un peu de fil non génétiques et
des salaires les plus bas salaires
ouais
c'est super c'est là c'est la première
émission qui rit c'est la première
émission tu vois passer le q2 pas fin à
il faut que je vous donne ma micro avec
moi mais j'ai toujours un micro avec moi
c'est de là qu'ils sont bien équipés
vous êtes un peu tout seul là là je suis
tout seul célibataire tout seul vous
voulez lancer un appel à télévision tu
cherches un québécois avec keynes qui
porte une serpillière appel au 0 800
plaisir je serai là pour toi par contre
j'ai essayé de d'endormir monfils et 24
rebonds weck a mal aux dents et qui il
votera vivait ses dents ouais il fait
ses dents tu veux raconter procès qu il
va pas dans ses nerfs à vif et où il est
maintenant
bienvenue de viol m vous êtes d'origine
arménienne
il aurait marqué un péno contre
l'arménie la passe quelque part tu veux
que l'étude reconnaissent le génocide
ton peuple
et quand tu as ton peuple m 11 vient les
allures vu pourtant comme un refus me
tamet c'est le port dimanche miss
auvergne à aurillac enfin et ça continue
comme ça je vois des gamins mais bien
dépensé alors maintenant on va baisser
la lumière et on va se la faire
interview dernier coup geneviève de
fontenay photos dont ça qu'on s'en va
bien geneviève dernier coup dur si tu
réponds ans après il va t'aider à
dernier comme ou christian baffy belle
fille maintenant je vais briser mois
quand m moi si je devais poser devant
qu'il serait pas aussi mal élevés vois
moi je ne le serai pas dire du magic va
bien oui je sais que javier stan m
d'ailleurs il vient d'avoir une deuxième
petite fille javier vient d'avoir une
deuxième petite fille bravo et xavier
c'est bien une petite fille il a bien
été obligé de mettre sa zigounette
dans l'est
c'était le best-of de la ce
bien alors va-t-il devenir un héros de
série sur tf1 va t-il se relancer dans
la politique
va-t-il reprendre l'om à nouveau tout le
monde en parle
voici les emmerdes
bernard tapie tu sens que mention
m
reste que toi je passe pour un de la
seule fois
pourtant bernard tapie bonsoir bonsoir
vous connaissez laurent baffie et comme
en aucun cas là j'ai un truc pour toi
vous êtes vus à à la première de canal
j'ai fait un cadeau
ouais mais n'a pas bravo a parlé tout à
l'heure dans la loge à dire à celles
d'origine parce que moi je l'avais
signer et faire et celle d'origine je
les garde voilà vous êtes libéré de
prison
voilà c'est une carte c'est une carte du
monopoly et non d'un fille avait offert
un verre lanta qui a les crocs n'auront
eux c'est le petit chat canal et oui
bernard bonsoir vouthon telle aventure
sur une chaîne une chaîne du câble
s'appelle rtl 9 ans l'émission s'appelle
rien à cacher c'est le dimanche à 19h20
donc et vous interviewer une
personnalité tous les dimanches mais
rtl9
vous êtes sûr bernard tapie que c'est
pas pour des raisons fiscales que vous
et non parce que c'est une société
française avant parce que le siège est à
paris bon vous êtes pas domicilié en
belgique en ce moment non j'aurais bien
voulu mais parce qu'il paraît que vous
recevez du courrier à vous et merci
c'est vrai puisque on respire la vérité
1 3 rond point de l'étoile à ixelles
c'est dans la banlieue de bruxelles chez
le bourg mais ce qui s'appelle yves de
jonghe d'ardoye des requins vicomte
il paraît que vous recevez du courrier
chez lui non c'est parce que j'ai été
député européen pendant longtemps et
quand on est député européen on habite
au moins trois jours par semaine en
belgique à dakar et donc j'habitais là
bas et c'est ce qui fait que j'ai eu une
adresse belge et que j'ai un lieu de
résidence bel msu pas résident dans la
mesure poids ce statut vous le savez le
fisc impose iphone oui on est plus de
sens eu plus de 160 jours par an voilà
donc moi dans ma pouvait être un pas qui
vous êtes des avoirs à l'étranger parce
que tout le monde l'an va être mon désir
tout voir est-ce que tapie pourrait il
aurait pas à l'étranger des comptes
machabee semblant j'en ai pas mais bien
sûr c'est pas seulement j'en ai pas peur
jamais jamais
[Musique]
sérieusement ils ont tellement cherché
mais tellement tellement tellement parce
que ça leur faisait plaisir
or il ya un truc que je comprends pas
vous avez plein d'ennuis et vous avez
toujours votre hôtel particulier rue des
saints-pères nono manger c'est une
occupation à la fois partiel est
momentanée ouais en fait la famille
tapie à l'hôtel particulier à la maison
ça c'est mental
[Musique]
c'est en fait perçu pour arriver à est
riche quand tu pars de canal c'est long
il ya un temps de réponse très long et
pour être pauvre quand on ne croit
arrive c'est bon aussi mais c'est des
membres des riches et des pauvres à la
temps je suis probablement dans un
statut fiscal unique au monde
unique au monde parce que aujourd'hui
j'ai de décrire la situation quand je
gagne 1000 francs dois je le dis à la
déjà avant que par le pognon c'est très
malin de mettre le plus de l'abbé pierre
ces digues en est la plus dégueulasse
parce que c'est pal avec l'ère du tout
c'est ta soeur thérésa alors tu te
souviens pas tu te souviens pas que on
va parler en anciens francs pour
bâtiments servant même pour ma mère
alors sans sac
ouais bon les impôts normal ils prennent
70 % ça fait cinquante comme je suis en
liquidation des biens ils prennent 30
puisque je donne un tiers la liquidation
donc je gagne 100 francs j'ai 50 francs
qui va au fisc rayons et 4 et 30 francs
non mais les à suivre donc hélas la
france irait un point final ben tant pis
ce groupe seulement maintenant comme les
doigts de mon fils et une amende en 95
parce que j'ai été assez content
maintenant va être mon bateau sous
pavillon français a tendance aussi prôné
les vins qu'on sait rien non tu vois
c'est vachement mieux
il faut que tous les français qui écoute
là ils se rendent compte qu'on est dans
un pays de malades quand je gagne 1000
maintenant les doigts ne prennent les
1000 rajouter 4 et rodman a d'abord et
après je paye 500 way au fisc et 300 ha
ha je suis le seul mec au monde
chaque fois je gagne un peu d'argent je
dois beaucoup d'argent puisque je crois
c'est vrai les vins qu'ils me prennent
s'appelle alors attendre non non mais
attends parce qu'à la limite le cumul
des différentes coiffer que tout le
monde à un moment donné vous en savez
quelque chose peut avoir affaire à eux
ce qui est construite à dépenser quand
il est un et le sel c'est le 7 août à
valence et à 5 en juin contre un
contrôle qui se finit vachement bien
il connaissait je connaissais strauss
kahn j'ai filé des cassettes pornos il
les a pas regardés là là où c'est pas là
où c'est pas bien et là où je pense que
je vais me fâcher et pour de vrai
attention c'est que quand mon syndic et
mon avocat arrive et dit aux douanes
m'attendais c'est une dette de 95
il ya donc l'argent cash là c'est à dire
que la norme vous pouvez vous faire
payer cash
ça les a pas intéressé autrement dit là
c'est plus dans le sens de l'intérêt du
public puisque l'intérêt du public c'est
toucher l'argent là plutôt que de
toucher les 5 millions d'âmes en cash
ils préfèrent aller m'emmerder sur mes
cachets de rtl9 de vol au-dessus d'un
nid de coucou de comédien
alors pourquoi pas ce qu'on vous a saisi
effectivement vos salaires de comédiens
avocat chez deux comédiens survol au
dessus d'un nid de coucou vos cachets
d'animateur sur la haine c'est est-ce
que c'est l'histoire du fossé a cédé 6
millions de francs que vous devez pour
le 25 5
pourquoi est ce que vous l'avez mis sous
pavillon français lui de mettre sous
pavillon panaméen
non parce que j'étais assez peu prudent
est ce qu'on fait je crois que c'est pas
de la volonté de s'extraire à l'impôt
que les gens mettent leur bateau sous un
pavillon étranger
c'est parce que les normes de la marine
marchande française sont devenus
tellement contraignantes qu'elles sont
pratiquement plus applicable ce plan
judiciaire on est tous bernard pasquet
toujours un procès en cours pour
banqueroute et détournements d'actifs
qui bloque en fait la procédure c'est
votre procédure vous d'attac contre le
crédit lyonnais
en fait vous avez déclenché une action
contre le crédit lyonnais vous pouvez
gagner beaucoup d'argent non parce que
c'est sur la vente d'adidas va si on
gagne ça vous êtes de nouveau très riche
je vais récupérer ce qu'on m'a pris je
fais beaucoup d'argent ça peut faire
beaucoup
en fait ce que vous dites c'est que
l'histoire d'adidas vous que racontez
nous la faire parce que c'est
intéressant comment vous vous êtes fait
spolier dans cette histoire d'adidas
nommé se faire spolier dans le monde des
affaires
il n'y a pas de quoi se faire plaindre
il m'est arrivé de deux roulés dans la
farine et de me faire rouler dans la
farine c'est une des règles de
du monde des affaires à condition que
résident les règles ce qui est pas
tolérable c'est quand vous donnez un
mandat de vente à un banquier pour en
mains de vos actifs qui vous prétend
l'avoir vendu 2 milliards et qu'en fait
le même jour il a revendu quatre et demi
ça s'en servir
on dit ça c'est pas bien pourquoi le
faire alors si c'est une banque mineurs
etc sans importance on peut se dire dans
ses dégoûts niafs mais dès lors que
c'est une grande banque nationalisée
avec à la tête des gens importants et
compétents on est en droit de dire c'est
un abus ce serait aux états unis la
vente est nulle
ouais bon c'est dire que s'il avait
aujourd'hui adidas reviens chez moi ça
vaut 35 milliards us
c'est bien et je vais vous donner un
autre chiffre marquant ils m'ont vendu
les actions d'adidas de tf1 100 millions
un cheval 4 milliards sommes donc c'est
pour vous dire que j'ai et le tribunal
actuellement depuis cinq ans on cherche
à savoir si on va le juger ou si on va
pas le juger c'est les lenteurs des
procédures est lente et plus vite pour
me coller en taule pour un match de
football
oui la promo il y en a qui ça va bien
j'ai de le faire toi et puis bernard
aussi
bon alors donc la pub s'est pas montrée
vol au-dessus d'un nid de coucou en
tournée rtl9 dès dimanche ses démarches
là à 19h20 sur rtl9 sur granit et c'est
qui santoni
sans évidemment bien alors et puis
attendez la up
attention il ya l'om ldc picdi la [ __ ]
là ça fait mal big deal
alors là moi je crois qu'on est bon ou
c'est non d'abord on va faire un petit
flashback au mba pour vous c'était le
début de la fin sinon c'était le déclic
dans votre vie c'était le début de la
fin ça a été le prétexte le prétexte
voilà on vous disait au début il ya
belle lurette le vaincu c'est quand je
fais 12 % aux européennes près faux
après bon après il aurait été ça ça
aurait pu être de la cam dans mon coffre
ça aurait pu être n'importe quoi kmv à
il y avait mellick
la semaine dernière il est génial on l'a
raconté son livre j'ai pas eu le temps
de winne
mais il est génial parce qu' ils
racontent une histoire apparemment
toujours la même et il a je crois fini
par y croire
alors je vais simplement dire ah ah ah
ah mon ami mais vic que j'adore parce
que c'est vraiment un mec caduc le
hacker fidèles que si j'avais été quoi
que ce soit quoi que ce soit dans la
construction de son faux témoignage
j'aurais été un peu inquiété pour faux
témoignage ou complicité de faux
témoignages bien
alors maintenant d'un tapis sérieusement
vous êtes juridiquement en mesure de
demander une licence de dirigeant de
club auprès de la ligue
oui parce que le droit en plus je vais
même vous en apprendre une carte qui est
passé à côté mais la ligue été condamné
pour me l'avoir retiré et il n'avait pas
le droit de me la retirer ça veut dire
qu'à calgary et il ya des juristes qui
sont allés un peu cherché voir et qui se
sont pas contentés de l'histoire du sac
enterrés dans le jardin et qui fait
qu'après le conseil d'état estimé en
confirmant que je devais avoir le droit
d'avoir une licence
alors robert louis dreyfus il voulait
pas partir maintenant ils partirent l1
je sais pas en tout cas il a dépensé
beaucoup d'argent pour ce réveillon pour
peu de résultats 600 millions vous aviez
mis 60 millions ouais une amie 600
milliards 10 et les merengues
c'est vrai qu'il a gagné dans la vida
seront donc lui la licence une erreur
avec le brouillon de groupe lui l'ami
600 millions avec ses 600 millions
finalement il n'est pas arrivé
à vous avec 60 ben oui bah ouais bah
ouais c'est un métier ça ouais alors est
ce que vous voulez vous aider robert
louis dreyfus
ah ah ah ah non regardez le club lui ça
son sort m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est là c'est le sort de
l'om
ouais et uniquement ça alors vous votez
à marseille domicilié ou la non mais
c'est à l'époque où j'étais simplement
conseiller régional conseiller
départemental et donc forcément lille
j'habite à marseille j'étais député des
bouches du rhône faisait toujours
électeurs à marseille ouais
alors votre vie commence par une
incertitude en fait la première
incertitude c'est sur votre naissance
dès le début il y avait déjà des
incertitudes avec vous bah oui je vous
est née sept mois après le mariage de
vos parents il ya deux solutions soit
vous êtes soit vous êtes en plus c'est
pas plus
ben si c'est pas vrai 26 janvier
quarante-trois voilà et vos parents sont
mariés en juillet donc ça fait sept mois
mais pas en 43 vous êtes dans son entier
43 vos parents vous ont conçu si vous
ont conçu en juillet 42 vous êtes né à
sept mois prématuré je suis né v6 en
faute et avant le mariage aura
dépassionner le débat et que l'amour
qu'elle joue lundi 10 le/la différentes
actrices tout mon père je ne crois tout
à fait capables d'avoir séduit maman est
comme ça fait maintenant 60 ans qui sont
mariés ensemble on peut éventuellement
leur pardonner d'avoir fait l'amour de
moelle et les deux mois voilà donc là
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est exactement
la formation docteur caractère comment
vous êtes devenu bernard tapie alors
quand vous êtes menés votre père était
au st lô en allemagne j'ai dit pour nos
amis qu'on pas connu ça c'est le service
du travail obligatoire si elle
comprenait des français pourrait
travailler en allemagne il ya beaucoup
de jeunes communistes de jeunes ouvriers
communistes qui avaient été emmenés en
allemagne au st lô et notamment georges
marchais ils étaient partis travailler
chez messerschmidt
alors votre père jean tapie était jean
baptiste deux mois le ta fiche et moi je
crois que votre problème vient de là
c'est à dire que finalement votre père
maintenant les espaces y est tu écoutes
le tueur leurs cartons problème commence
et j'ai même pas ton problème parce que
je vais d'excusés dans deux minutes et
que tu es gentil genre là je pense c'est
un problème de deep moi non mais sérieux
évidemment non mais voilà je vais vous
dire pourquoi on le savait d'ailleurs
votre père lui c'est un le bon ouvrier
le bon ouvrier communiste le vrai quoi
sur le type qui est dur à la tâche qui
veut s'élever socialement mais à force
de travail du tout pas du tout pas du
tout ce qu'on peut faire et et drag
queen a mis un bon ouvrier mon père
c'est un bon ouvrier comme air plein air
mais honnête sérieux c'est pas un
militant politique du régime acculé
militants politiques jeudi que lui pour
lui le travail s'est il veut s'élever
dans la hiérarchie sociale le travail il
veut il veut travailler pour nourrir ses
membres il fait des passes en 10 heures
par semaine dans des bernard quand il
vanne usine la journée que le soir il va
à l'école des arts et métiers s'élever
socialement pas du tout c'est pour avoir
du boulot et nourrir sa famille le vrai
problème c'est votre père c'est
quelqu'un de très rigoureux et vous
voulez que je vous le dise à prévoyez
durer six mois n'a rien à voir ça quand
vous êtes né dans un milieu qui soit peu
importe on va pas faire du misérabilisme
il ya plein de mômes qui sont très
malheureux d'être dans milieu à bourges
par exemple c'est quand vous êtes dans
un milieu et que l'environnement de ce
milieu ne vous plaît pas quel que soit
le milieu en question vous vous révoltez
d'une manière ou d'une autre il ya plein
de monde qui sont bourrés et qui se
foutent dans des mouvements trotskistes
ya 40 ans parce qu'il supportait plus
moi je ne supporte pas ce milieu parce
que c'est un milieu totalement
totalement soumis qui répond à rien et
de d'aucune manière à toutes les
agressions qu'on leur fait et à partir
du jour je deviens étudiants que je vais
à paris et donc je suis en contact de
mômes qui viennent d'ailleurs
il ya à la fois une révolte de ma part
de voir ces injustices car mon père est
intelligent il est travailleur
il bosse seulement il a baigné toute sa
vie dans un milieu qui lui permet pas de
ces lois là et cette injustice là me
fait chier voilà ça rien à voir avec un
complexe d'oedipe votre père jacques a
passé j'ai une vraie bagarre social vous
êtes d'une famille unie vraiment vous
êtes une famille où on n'est pas très
expansif votre père est plutôt renfermé
vous êtes plutôt hâbleur plutôt expansif
justement et vous voyez votre père
travailler jour et nuit et finalement
être traitée plutôt pas très bien et
vous vous dites pour réussir il ya
sûrement des raccourcis à prendre et ça
a été et ça a été la raison de votre
opposition à votre père jour au jour
jeudi explique la deuxième partie la
première partie on a compris pourquoi
des gosses pour sortir de leur milieu
font des efforts un peu surhumain alors
après il est question effectivement du
parcours qui est un parcours chaotique
sur lequel de temps en temps il ya une
ligne on franchit on la franchit pas ça
c'est autre chose
ça vient de deux phénomènes bien connu
le premier c'est que on connaît personne
et on connaît pas les règles et c'est
capital moi je vois mon fils y fait son
site trois jours après il à l'avocat qui
a déjà prévu un expert-comptable jouera
pas moi je connais aucune règle aucune
règle mais pas d affaire aucune règle
qui permettent à quelqu'un de s'élever
dans la société
donc je les invente et quand vous les
inventer vous êtes un parcours
initiatique vous faites des parcours bon
et des parcours move n ya personne pour
vous dire là c'est bien là c'est pas
bien donc vous découvrez au fur et à
mesure l'itinéraire que vous devez
prendre on est d'accord mais 22e le 2e
etc est aussi une des raisons du
handicap
si vous vous apercevez qu'on n'a pas
envie vous changer de catégorie
vous êtes bien là où ils assurent les
d'accord alors mais je suis d'accord
avec vous ce que je vous dis simplement
on sait que votre père lui il avait une
vision assez soumises effectivement des
choses vous vous dites c'est pas
possible je vais prendre des raccourcis
je suis innocent je suis révolté sari à
l'art avec les raccourcis et nerveux
je me suis par exemple jamais permis
tient jamais le car mais pas le cas 10%
vous savez thirion le juge richer a dit
dans un bouquin tapis à côté des grands
arnault pinault
c'est un enfant de choeur
parce que j'ai pas fait 10% bien sûr
parce que ce n'était pas du même milieu
social au départ bien sûr mais le
raccourci assène je vous reproche pas à
leur annoncer qu'il est matin peinture
et dangereux je commençais laisserait
supposer c'est pourquoi que je peux pas
laisser ce bout raccourcis souris soir
le mucha course il laisserait supposer
qu'on n'hésite pas de franchir les
règles pour aller plus vite c'est pas ça
du tout mais vous dites je connaissais
pas les règles toute façon mais je suis
d'accord mais c'est vrai que votre père
lui il avait une vision plutôt
traditionnel de la réussite
l'accumulation du travail du temps passé
et d'ailleurs vous est jamais arrivé à
l'impressionner votre père c'est à dire
qu'il a toujours été votre réussite il a
vécu comment il a vécu comme quelque
chose rires mais vous mais ça va pas il
était heureux à chaque fois et moi pour
le séduire j'étais content j'étais en
équipe de france juniors normes bâle il
venait voir tous les matches je faisais
des concerts de viol on y venait
assister au concert
c'est exact maire nous a nui aux
violences qui était prémonitoire ce
problème un soir j'aime bien a profité
que je suis faible et que là vous êtes
sans le défendre alors quand je dis
qu'il faut les parents mes parents ont
eu une vertu c'est de me donner et de
m'apprendre l'essentiel et je les en
remercie dans la mesure où c'est
l'essentiel qui m'a permis de tenir
l'expression n'a terminé là dessus mais
pourquoi votre père quand il a monté sa
peine dans les années 60 vous chercher
du boulot pourquoi vous n'avez jamais
engagé c'est bien parce que c'est un
problème mais pas du tout il sait des
camions réfrigérés et il a embauché mon
frère vous êtes dans ce milieu je dis
pas que ces causes est un vous avez un
appartement au bourget cet âge brina
voilà je dis simplement qu'à un moment
vous avez décidé de trahir notre classe
sociale parce que c'est une façon mais
c'est pas reproche c'est une façon de le
volailler vous en sortir une vraie
question d'ailleurs allé poser souvent à
ceux qui comme moi change
est-ce que c'est l'exemplarité de votre
réussite qui est positive et qui peut
donner envie à d'autres de dire c'est
possible donc on va le faire il ya eu le
cas est-ce que c'est au contraire une
manière totalement irréel et j'allais
dire insultante de faire croire à des
jantes sont des imbéciles puisqu'ils le
font pas il ya eu qu'à aussi donc comme
tous les symboles et quand vous faites
des choses un peu qui sortent de
l'ordinaire vous est symbolique
j'ai eu ma part de
exemple j'ai été positif et utile à
certains et j'ai été une catastrophe
pour d'autres c'est ce qui fait que dans
ce pays les gens qu'ils m'adorent et des
gens qui me détestent parce que je dis
simplement c'est qu'à l'époque quand
vous allez au bord de la marne à la fin
des vacances avec votre mère deux frères
c'était non mais c'était génial vous
souffriez mais génial je traînais dans
la main visiblement qu'à un moment vous
vous dis c'est pas c'est bon la vraie
vie c'est pas ça et pour s'en sortir
quand on est dans votre cas ya deux
solutions il ya la boxe où le
rock'n'roll et vous avez choisi la
chanson c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
changer au défunt bonne nuit et s'est
passée mieux c'est pas mieux mais pas
mieux c'est pas salé téméraire voulez
pas vous sortir de votre classe sociale
et vous cherchez de maintenant je vais
essayer de sortir de la soumission c'est
à dire quand je n'ose pas vous le dire
parce que je vais encore être un mauvais
exemple
mais je considère que par exemple voilà
la manière dont un représentant de la
force publique parle
un ouvrier dans sa voiture qui rit un
feu rouge m insupportable et maintenant
il me parle plus de cette façon là et je
suis content qu'il me parle plus de
cette façon et j'aurais aimé qu'ils
parlent pas de cette façon là mon père
qui disait rien quand on le faisait lé
dakor premier boulot c'est quoi j'ai
vendu des téléviseurs des géniales
c'était génial parce que c'est une
époque où il y en avait pas et donc
j'avais convaincu le gars qui étaient
venus pour n'en vendra que s'il les
prêtait avec une antenne pendant
quelques jours il ya de grandes chances
qu'ils auraient pu envie de le laisser
repartir
il m'a dit tu crois on en a mis 12 dans
un camion et sept minutes après l'es12
était placé les gens qui sortaient de la
rue hôtel moi j'en veux aussi moi j'en
veux aussi et puis file en huit jours
après avec est-ce que ce n'était pas
déjà une façon de piéger les bobos ça je
sais pas s'ils ont un téléviseur c'est
puis l'a laissé pendant huit jours en
disant attend prochainement vous disiez
pas simple certains instituts de
sondages en fait des études sur la télé
ni c'est donc on vous laisse le
téléviseur peut voir ce que vous pensez
des programmes et oui c'est vrai ce qui
ne peut pas l'accuser d'être un mauvais
vendeurs de à ça non mais je l'accuse
côté des vendeurs qui te vendent un truc
qui te disent regarder l'écran dans 30
ans j'y suis chapeau noter les quelques
clients auxquels je vous dis aujourd'hui
après toutes ces aventures pas fini le
bilan aujourd'hui je parle à moi je ne
sais pas faire un bilan à un moment
donné de la vie parce que à 48 heures
près tu vois imagine je gagne mon procès
contre le lyonnais dans quinze jours
quand on se revoit je suis pas le même
que si je le perds ouais bah quand on se
revoit vous achetez tout la france deux
mois lui doublement j'achète pas moins
vous achetez plus le nom du pot de colle
sérieusement vous avez su vous n'êtes
pas suivi toujours les conseils de votre
père et mon père il n'est pas
prétentieux au point de vouloir me
donner des conseils dès lors que je
quittais le chemin qu'il avait lui-même
parcouru le conseil s'est quand même pas
abstrait c'est mon expérience me permet
de te dire attention fais pas ça mon
père dès lors que je quitte la maison je
fais des choses réelles père il avait
une autre façon que vous de voir les
choses totalement
il est discret il est modeste il est de
il est il est réfléchi à tous dans tous
les sens du terme
il est manuel il est capable de
fabriquer n'importe quoi moi non ouais
on est on est pas pareil
avant serge pas voir la lumière là
avant de quitter ce sujet est ce que
vous dites pas à sérieusement des fois
sérieusement quand vous êtes pas
maintenant parce que vous allez bien ça
marche
mais quand vous étiez en cage comme vous
dites vous n'êtes pas l'idée fois
j'aurais mieux fait d'écouter mon père
mon père avait raison
bien mal acquis ne profite jamais ce
genre de choses on se dit donc j'ai
l'impression d'avoir mal acquis et vous
êtes jamais dit mon père avait raison
non finalement sa vie à lui qui est
humble qui est une vie simple et humble
finalement j'aurais été plus heureux si
j'avais accepté cette villa non mais
attendez je vais vous expliquer quelque
chose
il a été très heureux avec maman way qui
depuis 60 ans et sa femme où on a fêté
ensemble 190 m
oui mais vous voulez pas attendre suivi
ça rires oui moi ça fait 28 ans que je
suis avec la mienne je suis aussi
heureux que lui avec la sienne malgré le
parcours très différents or comme mon
bonheur conjugal compte autant que lui
et que ma vie perte professionnel compte
après et que j'ai pas eu de rater de ce
côté là je suis très heureux c'était la
question qui tue
non
bien alors maintenant dans cette
émission le public n'est pas là que pour
faire ça il peut aussi poser des
questions qui me poser des questions
alors un tapis vous là mais ici c'est un
moyen de rencontrer des filles on vous
appelez comment karine karine je vais
vous poser une question
ça vous arrive de pleurer pour de vrai
cette évidence évidemment et quand je
suis allé en prison je vous fais une
confidence je m'y étais préparé puisque
je les suis trois mois al avance je
m'étais vraiment préparés parce qu'on
m'avait dit fais du training c'était
donc je m'étais avait nagé en bas dans
ma call un lieu totalement noire sans
fenêtre sans rien et j'y faisais des
petits morceaux de temps après et
j'étais certain d'arriver à subir
l'épreuve sans aucun doute et j'avais
dit en partant j'avais dit ça va se
passer comme une lettre à la poste et
deux heures et demie après tu vois pas
huit mois après deux heures et demie
après quand le faux bond c'est fermé
j'ai vu mon fils qui m'a vu monter et
malheureusement lui me voyais plus est -
à travers les grilles je voyais mon fils
et mon fils époux pencher sur son volant
et s'est mis à pleurer lui et là j'étais
par terre
donc je croyais avoir être capable de
tenir lui moi j'ai tenu deux heures et
demie merci
[Applaudissements]
vous appelez comme en amérique ou qui je
la reconnais et oui c'est cher payé un
truc qui est sûr c'est qu'on va
reconnaît un mois c'est pour les
tee-shirts mouillés c'est bardé ceci dit
et le t-shirt mouillé il ya longtemps
qu'on vous l'a fait là venant de toi je
m'attendais à mieux quand même a dit à
la remise
koki la dernière fois que tu es venu ça
a déclenché une guerre avec madame de
fontenay
donc aujourd'hui s'ajuster confiance en
elle en a gardé par un gâteau non plus
tu as quel est justement je vais essayer
de ne pas profiter de votre faiblesse
puisque on en parlait tout à l'heure
vous le grand charmeur le beau parleur
trois mois et demi de prison sans femmes
à six mois alors pardon alors c'est pire
justement 100 femmes est-ce que c'était
pas trop dur
comme tout le monde j'ai regardé canal+
la prochaine pub c'est canal+ la chaîne
des branleurs les y pense il travaille
là dessus
[Musique]
bien là maintenant on va faire une
interview dans la peau d'un autre
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas dans le jingle à avoir
commencé la dj renvoie le jingle non
parce qu attendez je vais dire un truc
avant de railler jingle je serai pas
vous avez bougé oui il ya une fille qui
me dit elle me dit est ce que chez nous
elle m'envoie un email est-ce que chez
nous aussi on doit pas bouger pendant le
jingle ben je dis oui bien sûr un temps
mais qu'est ce que c'est ça mais alors y
avait une qui vit alors y en a une autre
qui s'appelle corps d'un bébé mais en
allant didier elle maintenant je tiens à
dire ça parce qu'effectivement d'abord à
la maison ne doit pas bouger par le
jingle comme ici et elle dit c'est pas
possible de baisers pendant tout le
monde en parle parce que toutes les
trois minutes faut lever la main pour la
promo où il faut pas bouger pendant le
jingle je sais c'est compliqué en cause
les trucs comme apaisé le sanwi passe
des trucs de la mer comprend pas pour
servir compliqué donc on y retourne
didier on ne bouge pas pendant les ting
[Musique]
et bien voilà c'est pas compliqué répond
pas un jour il y aura des manifestations
tu veux attirer alors va jouer un jeu
donc c'est dans la peau d'un autre si
une nouvelle interview dont vous êtes
dans la peau de chirac par exemple je
réponds comme il devrait répondre selon
moi ou comme je pense qu'ils
répondraient lui avoue répondait comme
vous pensez qu'ils répondraient lui 1
alors si je vous dis par exemple comme
alliot-marie vous est expliqué sur la
cassette jacques chirac je vois pas
pourquoi on continue à vous embêter
c'est tout à fait vrai ouais vous pensez
que vous êtes expliqué ben oui puisque
j'y vis j'y étais pour rien et je suis
respectueux de la fonction et je suis
président de la république sans
conneries sur cette cassette jeudi je me
suis expliqué si vous êtes de nouveau
chirac je vous dis qu'il ya une rumeur
sur votre santé que vous êtes un peu
comme pompidou à l'époque d'alsatic j'ai
un peu grossi parce que vous prenez de
la cortisone alors c'est la cortisone ou
la bière dont vous avez vu je suis parti
en vacances avec avec ma femme et mon
nas à lyon on a bouffé non mais bon là
non pas moi c'est que il ay là c'est
vrai il a dû se laisser aller
ouais vous pensez que c'est la picole et
la bouffe ouais je crois bien alors
imaginez vous soyez jeu ce pas oui et je
vous dis vous avez fait douze pages dans
gala cette semaine est ce que c'est si
malin que ça à lionel de montrer le luxe
dans lequel vous vivez à matignon même
si sandra et blanc écoutez on n'arrête
pas de me dire que finalement je suis
très intelligent pas chirac
ouais je suis très performant pas chirac
je suis travailleur pas chirac et tous
les sondages le donnent perdant face à
chirac je demande à mes conseillers
pourquoi on dit parce qu'ils y vont
jouer à tout le monde qu'il a une bonne
gray qui sourit du bombe a fait moi
sourire c'est plus facile de faire des
rajouts redirai lionel que chirac et
tous le cul des vaches et que vous vous
apprêtez à matignon dans un luxe de pala
attendez je suis pas au bout
ah ouais je commence par ça d'accord
mais je vais finir dans le pré des
vaches d'accord ça va très bien là vous
êtes de nouveau chirac vous allez tuer
jus comme enjeu spa avant 2002 je vais
tuer comment jospin avant 2002 jacques
ça va pas être facile comment vous allez
faire je vais lui proposer de prendre
debré comme ministre êtes vous en sortez
bien jacques et vous lionel comment vous
avez tué chirac en 2002 je vais demander
à ma garde des sceaux de continuer de ne
pas s'occuper des affaires comme elle
s'en occupe pas
[Musique]
bernard merci merci des mercis la bonne
chance pour pour rtl9 et puis vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou donc en
tournée et bientôt je vous signale que
je vous ai invités à venir sur votre
tour je viendrais volontiers c'est à
dire merci c'était bernard tapie
lors de l'émission alors à avant de
passer à mon avis tu es suivant je vais
faire un petit point sur les invités de
la semaine précédente parce qu'on reçoit
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup du mail alors
il y avait une invitée la semaine
dernière qui est claire castillon qui a
écrit le grenier
alors là c'est terrible quand j'ai des
tas d'e-mails tout le monde me demande
si elle est libre alors je crois avoir
été assez claire pendant les interviews
tout on a bien compris qu'elle n'était
pas vraiment libre sur djorkaeff alors
bravo sur l'arménie
il ya que des mecs qui s'appelle des
noms en riant qui me disent bravo
d'avoir posé des questions à djorkaeff
sur l'arménie
et puis il ya un mec qui s'appelle la
grange qui me dit est ce que tu aimes
vraiment sa chanson je préfère quand ils
jouent au foot
voilà bien alors maintenant va-t-elle
faire oublier claire castillon voix si
ça marche
[Musique]
c'est dur ça non soir ça va oui ça va le
faire c'est normal comment ça va lancer
la semaine des collections n'est content
de profiter de votre présence à paris
sahara pour vous avoir sur le plateau
vous connaissez laurent baffie tout à
l'heure j'ai 19 ans tout le monde le
sait est la petite fille de michel maure
quand votre père alors c'est qu'on va se
compliquer votre père c'était le fils
c'est toujours le fils de michel morand
et de bill marshall veut percer mike
marshall donc qui était le le fils de
michel maure gants et de bill marshall
et votre tante may bouton de par
alliance en fait c'est tony marshall qui
a fait vénus beauté institut qui est un
film adorable et elle c'est la fille de
bill marshall et de micheline presle
parce que le fameux bill marshall après
michel maure gants ou avant après on a
commencé à entendre parler de vous en 94
saviez 13 ans et vous étiez au bal des
débutantes et vos parents vous laisser
sortir à 13 ans s'était pas vraiment une
sortie le bal des débutants à
s'impliquer c'est chaperonner et aucun
d'entre eux à 13 ans le bal des
débutantes et à 15 ans mancka pareil
liberté totale
williams et moi maman mais a été
toujours là allez d'acteurs sont comme
libéro là vos parents n'ont ou c'est
vous qui êtes une vraie rebelle non
riche en essais libres sur à ses dépens
et pourquoi mannequin parce que l'état
vous êtes dentiste oui c'est sûr que
j'ai changé d'opinion je voulais être
dentiste parce que la science
m'intéressait beaucoup ça fait la
journée dans la bouche des gens
pourquoi sérieuse dans le recul je pas
laurent que l'image août proctologue
ouais parce que moi je croyais que vous
aviez transformer votre vocation de
dentiste en vocation de mannequins parce
que vous étiez tout ce qui brille les
paillettes le show business à vous
plaisait pas du tout en fait
justement on va y venir on va y venir
parce que voulais être comédienne
justement et vous prenez des cours avant
de vous lancer si vous êtes une fille
sérieuse dit je veux pas y aller comme
ça hein et vous prenez des cours avec
qui je prends des cours avec un
professeur qui est membre de l'actors
studio il s'appelle jack white sa voix
vous avez pas au conservatoire parce que
j'ai pas le temps de rester six mois à
paris sans bouger donc pour l'instant
c'est quoi la me conviennent très bien
je veux vraiment être comédienne il
faudrait sacrifier votre tant pis pour
le mannequinat vous tant pis vous allez
au conservatoire non je sais que pour
être mannequin faut pas manger beaucoup
mais il faut quand même gagner de
l'argent pour manger
donc j'ai besoin de travailler c'est
vrai les gens comme moi on s'imagine ont
dit à petite fille de michel morvant
elle doit être pour itunes en fait pas
du tout vous n'avez pas d'argent au
départ c'est sûr que c'est bien mais je
préfère me débrouiller toute seule elle
a dormi dans les cartons d'invitation un
simple différend datant des boulettes
mais ça fait quatre ans vous dites que
vous l'êtes comédienne mais avec votre
famille les relations vous avez vous
auriez pu faire des petits rôles les
jalons et ben ma famille m'aide pas
beaucoup à quelle bande d'enculés
mais je sais pas gérard où il a fait
plein de films
pourquoi un moment vous auriez pu quand
même avoir des petits rôles dans les
films de votre beau grand père oui mais
géra rien padula vue il ne tourne plus
beaux coups de fil mais moi je me lance
dans la comédie seulement maintenant
donc je préfère apprendre avant tout
donc il ya quatre ans j'aurais pas pu
jouer dans un de ses films parce que je
savais pas jouer et je dis pas que je
sais jouer maintenant déjà mais j'ai une
fille sérieuse en fait c'est vrai c'est
m'amuser mais sinon pas bon alors
justement en 97 dans match vous avez
déclaré toutes mes copines ont des
petits amis et vous vous êtes pas encore
connu ce sentiment
quel sentiment ce sentiment ce sentiment
dans par le mur à sénou sentiment
nouveau vous dit que pour le moment on
va vous disiez 797 donc j'espère pour
vous ça a changé depuis pour le moment
les gardes sont c'est un peu comme les
gâteaux c'est un peu l'interdît quoi
depuis ce s'arranger maintenant les
diabétiques je vois pas sérieusement ça
va mieux avec 197 c'est très inquiétant
cette déclaration la toutes vos copines
ont des petits copains sauf vous ça va
mieux
[Musique]
bon ça va très bien très jolie en plus
très bien habillé c'est votre ami j 3
qui vous habille jean claude jitrois
jean claude jitrois j 3 couleurs alors
j'ai ça âgées animal à sang c'est alors
je pense que c'est bruno non c'est pas
sur vous ça sera la semaine prochaine et
je vous le dirai d'ailleurs mais là
c'est un dénommé masure et moi je je
pense que c'est bruno masure parce que
bon il dit thierry ardisson je regarde
chaque semaine votre émission il n'y a
pas assez de scènes hot
je pense que ces bonhommes azur et il
propose l'interview strip tease donc on
peut essayer un il dit quand l'invité
une répond mal il doit enlever un habit
écailles du surinam oui on peut
commencer par les chaussures n'aura pas
faire ça non va vers ça parce que ça
serait vraiment un
on peut pas faire ça non c'est con et
font pas cette idée comme ça si on
répond pas des patients canal ah oui
c'est vrai heureusement d'ailleurs bien
en refaire une autre irait oui elle a
raison je parle
oui cibafi parle c'est qu'on n'est pas
sur canal c'est bien sagement rien pour
opérer la chaîne non on va faire on va
faire quand même
- cochon l'interview [ __ ]
encore moins qu'aux non on va faire
l'interview première fois vous
connaissez la table première fois non
j'ai beaucoup regardé l'émission et à
l'inter de vous allez voir alors on ne
bouge pas pendant le tinker
[Musique]
vous bougez bien et je vais vous dire
normalement doit pas vous un jour les
gens descendront dans la rue avec des
banderoles pour vous à l'heure où on
parle il ya des gens qui sont sur leur
lit en train de regarder la télé alors
justice est en train de faire l'amour et
pendant le jingle sont obligés de
s'arrêter
vous allez bouger mais je vous pardonne
parce que vous bougez bien vous êtes
prête qu on attaque une première fois
c'est très soft au début un flux le
premier souvenir premiers souvenirs de
votre vie quand vous fermez les yeux
vous pensez vous êtes tout petit nom
fermez pas les yeux finalement c'est
ridicule leur demander de fermer les
yeux avoue je pense à ma mère
ah oui le premier mensonge là j'en ai
trop dit pour m'en souvenir
ah bon à vous monter beaucoup quand on
veut être comédienne faut s'entraîner
tôt en 97 selon vous disiez que vous
n'aviez pas de petite amie c'était un
mensonge
non là c'est un mensonge
le premier péché qu'appelez vous
empêchez pas empêché sait faire des
choses qui sont interdites par la part
la morale ou par la bonne éducation
c'est par la religion ça dépend on va
peut-être pas en parler c'était kippour
ya deux jours ouais c'était pas donné
tout est pardonné
bon c'est fini pêcher depuis kippour
d'avoir menti
votre premier amour en souvenez je
l'attends toujours en réalité ah bon
mais qu'est ce qui est bon je me
souviens de mon premier copain mais
sachez très intéressant sahara khatun
toujours ah bon elle a pas de mec mais
le copain c'était comme ça c'était pas
vraiment sérieux quoi non mais attendez
non mais vous savez que vous ouvrez là
il ya des millions de français qui se
disent je peux être son premier amour en
régie aussi mais je préfère les italiens
n'ont aucune chance
moi je suis venu ici moi j'ai 10 ans
italiens et a aucune chance que même
ses valeurs d'origine italienne ou à
moitié on peut dire les choses sur un
plateau et d'autres choses dans un
parking
la soirée n'est pas terminée bien votre
premier baiser c'est avec ce qu par là
abon ses avances
mon premier baiser je ne devais avoir 5
ans avec la langue
c'est un peu plus tard un peu plus tard
six ans c'est en l1 après 97 après 97
votre premier lapin mais je n'ai pas
encore posé de lapin c'est très ponctuel
à beaucouzé pas de lapin non je
téléphone à vous prévenez assez dense et
bien élevé en fût ce votre première
idole final pas grand vous idolâtrez
personne même pas des gens qui font de
la télévision et tous à negage ses
comptes la religion ah oui c'est vrai
vous êtes religieuse sérieux vous êtes
commandant les ruptures vous êtes vous
téléphonez ou si vous faites comme pour
les lapins non là je préfère convoqué
ouais même une question je l'étais de se
faire virer par vos annonces et francs
votre premier chagrin d'amour
j'ai pas beaucoup pleuré a nettement
n'hésitent pas un peu trop froide donc
sérieux là je vous écoute et ça je
commence à avoir un petit problème là je
vous ai je vous écoute vous je bois vos
paroles puis je me dis c'est peut-être
normal que vous n'ayez pas de grand
amour parce que vous avez l'air très
froides quand même très non mais je me
protège un peu trop peut-être qu'on fait
à toutes les blondes aux yeux bleus
ouais un peu comme ça à distendre froid
ça se trouve elle est très chaude et on
le sait même pas non mais c'est vous que
vous pouvez protéger trop non en fait je
me protège pas trop parce que dans ma
famille il ya eu beaucoup de divorces tu
fais comme ça beaucoup de ruptures
sentimentales jeu j'ai vu les gens
souffrir et j'ai pas envie de souffrir
comme ça donc je sais que c'est
difficile et à la première cuite
je n'ai pas eu encore n'ont jamais pris
une cuite non pas des vrais noms
champagne non sérieux la médaille je
suis sûr que si vous me donnez un verre
de champagne chez vous et sa 106 premier
pétard au maintien ma mère regarde
devant attendait alors vous vous
éloignez du téléviseur s'appelle comment
votre maman sylvie tu peux aller à la
cuisine se blesse il visionne minutes tu
vas te chercher un verre de chambord ou
la patine mais je suis sûr votre mère
fumait vous le savez pas bon c'était y'a
pas longtemps toute façon votre dernière
volonté si vous deviez mourir là
maintenant ce serait d'avoir fait un
film
[Musique]
voilà je reçois maintenant quelqu'un qui
voulait changer l'école pour une bonne
raison ils pensent que
r ils pensent que l'école est finie
voici collègues à pile à nous sans
prétention vraie mauvaise réputation
mais nous lui reste moi je passe tous là
je ne sais quoi veulent en fait pourtant
de dollars comment ça va très bien alors
tapie n'était pas très content
info contactez regarde derrière
[Applaudissements]
les fils rouges détendez-vous claude bon
j'ai aucun problème mais je sais que
vous êtes quelqu'un de solide parce que
vous avez un problème d tenu tête au
snes donc vous êtes quelqu'un de solide
il a payé ça tape il a payé il a fait sa
prison maintenant un non événement on a
payé sa dette à la société en devient
fréquentable non pour que voulait pas le
voir je suis pas venu ici pour voir
monsieur tapie s'il veut me voir il n'a
qu'à demander rendez vous je le recevrai
je verrais très bien l'affairé close
bonsoir monsieur le ministre
donc pardon bonsoir le ciel mais ni
statut non mr claude on l'appelle 1
claude puel monsieur le ministre tout le
temps ça me dérange ni dans un sens ni
dans les draps blancs claudio ne fait
pas emmerder alors après un passage
remarqué au ministère l'éducation
nationale vous publié chez fayard toute
vérité est bonne à dire la falloir faire
il a fondé la fin parce que tu vous tuer
un de mes deux éditeurs ils vont pas
être contents mais alors là vous êtes
obligé de faire ça je suis désolé mais
tout le monde le fait c'est à dire c'est
à dire que les faire ça doit passer pour
un con
le rebel vous n'avez pas remarqué
si si si j'ai remarqué là si vous avez
une tête je suis né rebelles et je
mourrai rebel rebel ça veut dire quelque
chose ça veut dire ne pas admettre ce
que tout le monde admet tout le temps si
on pense que ce n'est pas bien et par
conséquent ça veut dire ne pas être
récupéré par la société jamais seraient
récupérés par la société vous êtes mieux
que cédric heure-là on sait pas qui on
sait pas qui est claude allègre moi j'ai
voulu dire à la fin de cette interview
c'est pas du tout c'est un grand
chercheur un grand savant et on va se
demander un petit peu pourquoi vous êtes
parti dans cette histoire politique
parce que vous êtes beaucoup plus vous
valez mieux que la politique alors votre
bouquin s'appelle toute vérité est bonne
à dire je suis au regret de vous dire
c'est un truc à moi
moi j'ai lancé un journal en 92 qui
s'appelle entrevue je les vends durant
95 je rassure tout le monde mais le
slogan c'était toutes les vérités sont
bonnes à dire c'est pas oui mais vous
dis toute vérité est bonne à bien c'est
un peu pompé claude non non pas du tout
je savoir ya une très grande différence
expliquez moi je n'ai pas dit toutes les
vérités sont bonnes à dire
il ya des dents les dans le
fonctionnement de l'état ya des choses
qui sont pas à dire bien alors bon vous
tout le monde connaît alors quand on dit
claude allègre dans la rue là si on
descend dans la rue ou sur demande à
tous les amis qui sont là c'est le
mammouth il faut dégraisser le mammouth
quoi c'est vraiment votre truc
codalet il faudrait expliquer dans le
livre comment c'est venu comment c'est
venu claude racontez-nous là vous êtes
là pour ça non de boer s'est même pas
moyen mahmudi explique à nos amis c'est
l'éducation nationale a annoncé
l'ajustement les yeux le mammouth celle
à l'administration centrale de
l'éducation nationale ce mou n'a pas été
inventé par mois il avait été inventé
dans un livre en recevant des
journalistes d'une manière off avant une
conférence de presse
j'ai dit je veux assouplir l'éducation
nationale je veux ramener les gens plus
près du terrain je veux arrêter de ce
gouvernement de paris qui gouvernent
tous les deux et par conséquent je veux
aller j'ai cette structure centrale et
j'ai dit
c'est comme dirait tout le monde puisque
c'était le nom de l'auteur il faut
dégraisser un peu ce mammouth envoyer
les gens sur le terrain le lendemain en
première page du monde il y avait un
dessin de plantu et une d'un titre
dégraisser le mammouth qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je fasse que jeter les
saisies sont bien que l'autre c'était of
s'était offert que vous l'aviez dit
comme on sait se passe tout le temps
fait et c'était quelque chose de rigueur
à prendre les way we vous été piégé par
le monde
absolument c'est pour ça que vous lisez
un bel monde par deux jours je ne lis
plus le monde effectivement qui n'est
plus le journal digne de votre
adolescence mais qui fait des gros
titres pour appâter le chaland
qu'est ce que je pense et ce que vous
pensez alors aujourd'hui quand vous
dites finalement le mammouth c'est sympa
je préfère dinosaures parce que c'est
encore plus préhistorique que les
mammouths ca s'est passé là c'est plus
offre quand vous dites ça maintenant non
parce que j'assume tout quand je si je
veux parler de l'éducation nationale et
cette fois pas du l'image du dinosaure
et plus est meilleure que celle du
mammouth d'accord ou à ce qu'il faut
beaucoup de temps pour les du cerveau
halak voilà c'est dit vécu ça pour ça
qu'il ya le viagra est pour ça qu elle
viagra et si koné comme ça à la a vu un
premier petit ami à seulement deux ans
mais si vous avez fait la formation
accélérée mon petit je viens vous parler
du langage l'éducation nationale alors
c'est vrai que c'est insensé le
référentiel bondissant sais ce que c'est
selon le référentiel bondissant les
couilles marchande
sarah le référentiel bondissant non je
sais pas ce que ça lui on me paye pour
dire kouyate affole pas c'est normal il
ya des gros gros tout le monde rigole
c'est normal d'avoir ce des emails en
disant encore dans le référentiel
bondissant c'est le ballon ah oui mais
c'est très rigolo
il ya par exemple à un moment donné
parce que il ya même il ya même peuvent
élire vrai
le référentiel bondissant aléatoire
pressé le ballon de rugby par exemple
quand on dit nicolas pourrait dire lors
s'investit dans son espace extérieur
veut dire quoi
qui va se promener non je regarde par la
fenêtre je regarde par la fenêtre a
conduit par exemple un atelier de
motricité rapprocher la pénétration non
faire moi je fêterai c'est son job mais
non mais ça pourrait être ça oui mais
non c'est pour apprendre à écrire voilà
d'accord alors donc déjà bon c'est un
bond absolument inscrire un nouveau
rebond alesi que dans un livre qui est
paru qui est parfait par mois uniquement
sur le langage qui est fait par deux
deux professeurs alors j'ai appris et
géniteur d'apprenants sachets lipton ses
parents d'élèves très les parents
d'élèves géniteur d'apprenants il faut
savoir ce que c'est l'éducation
nationale alors vous êtes attaqués au
snes quel syndicat national de
l'enseignement secondaire et la
secrétaire générale s'appelle monique
vue il ya c'est ça s'appelait s'appelait
ouais et alors vous savez pas été votre
copine l'a dit à beyrouth quand vous
êtes arrivé j'aurais sa peau elle l'a
eue remarquer d'une certaine façon oui
oui alors vous avez vous avez attaqué
bille en tête le syndicat des profs à 10
ans d'une certaine façon
et puis les profs alors vous à venir
c'est vrai ou pas parce que vous avez
comme une fâcheuse tendance claude à
dire des trucs là prêts à dire non ce
parlement dise alors est ce que vous
avez dit qu'il ya par exemple en parlant
des profs qui a beaucoup d'absentéisme
dans l'éducation nationale
il y à 13 % d'enfants qui n'ont pas le
leur professeur en face d'eux bien un
peu plus même puisque les les absences
de moins de 48 heures ne sont pas
comptabilisés
bien après remplacement il y en a encore
6 % qui n'ont pas de profs mais un
remplaçant c'est pas le prof normal
deuxième chose
une partie de ces absences sont dus à
des maladies tout ça c'est normal il n'y
a pas dit à discuter là dessus ou et
congé de maternité mais une partie des
absences sont organisées par l'éducation
nationale c'est à dire que l'éducation
nationale fait la formation continue
pendant les heures de classe
après que des gens qui ont quatre mois
et demi de vacances il pourrait prendre
quatre jours dans l'année pour faire la
formation continue ou bien on organise
des réunions enseignant pendant les
heures de classe
enfin quand par exemple que dans les
manifs ou d'envoyer certains ont trouvé
ce thierry oui parce que je les ai vus
d'accord première fois mais nous on vous
reproche rien attendez attendez tous
parler vrai je te plaît plutôt je trouve
que c'est non non non non non je vous le
dis je trouve que le métier de
professeur
c'est pas n'importe quel métier et il ya
des choses qu'on doit pas faire de la
même manière que traiter vers des manifs
avec un qui le ronge ce serait pas
traiter tous les profs retraités le
ministre de bouffon faut pas s'étonner
après si les élèves vous traite de
bouffon devant lors donc voila vous en
prenez au mammouth aux dinosaures
et puis finalement je ce passé votre
votre ami enfin cesser de longue date
rend pas revenir là-dessus mais quand
même un jour il vous lâche parce que bon
voilà il est obligé de vous lâcher parce
qu'il n'est pas de choix alors ça c'est
passé une fin c'est vous qui le dites
bah il n'avait pas envie de perdre les
élections mais ça c'est vous qui le
dites les profs pour jospin c'est vous
qui le dites et je te soutiens a choisi
aussi dit moi alors non je veux dire qui
il a fait un choix un certain moment sur
deux manifs deux manifs pavin et il a
fait le choix de modifs de changer le
gouvernement
en changeant - changeant le ministre de
l'économie et des finances le ministre
de la culture et demi la fonction
publique c'est son choix mais il n'était
pas obligé ce que je suis n'est pas
obligé il l'a fait passer comme il veut
garder comme on sait que dans un canton
et facial il a fait les preuves c'est
important quand vous dites en marquant
en parlant de jospin vous dites il
voulait réussir à travers monts
ce qu'il avait raté lui même et c'est
vrai que jospin avait été remplacé à
l'éducation nationale par langue déjà un
par jack lang il avait eu des manifs
aussi à l'époque de mitterrand
c'est à dire que je sens un peu comme
mitterrand finalement y virent ses
ministres éducation nationale pour
mettre jacques lang à la place peut-être
lunel c'est peut-être une habitude jack
lang
c'est pas très gentil d'être vient quand
on est cantonné jospin est retraité de
mitterrand c'était très sympa pourquoi
parce que mitterrand c'est quand même
pas la preuve de probité incarner quand
même hein ah mais attendez j'ai présenté
jospin et beaucoup je pense moi
personnellement c'est léger mais macy's
et jc decaux mitterrand j'ai précisé je
veux pas rentrer dans ces dans ce
problème j'ai précisé qui était
l'héritier au sens politique du tout
d'accord et j'ai bien précisé que sur le
plan financier chez soi tous précisé sur
le plan de la delà de la de l'éthique de
la vie personnelle et c'était deux
personnes très différentes pourraient
bien porter de jugement on a bien
compris monsieur le ministre jack lang
qui dit en parlant de vous dans le
canard enchaîné alors ça vaut ce que ça
vaut mais ça a été un ministre
abominable ça a été quatre années de
mensonges et de régression hall alors
vous ne pouvez pas me faire penser que
c'est ce que dit langue de moins il a
bien dit avant les présidentielles en
que jospin était un looser ça je crois
qu'il l'a dit publiquement pas dans le
canard enchaîné ouais parce que quand on
peut dire je sais pas at elle nous a
manqué c'est là il est ministre et pas
vous alors que vous avez été je vous
avais déjà dit j'ai été ministre pendant
un moment et lui l'était pas vrai bien
la façon de faire de la politique de
langues
vous avez déclaré c'est un peu le
symbole longue c'est un peu le symbole
d'une d'une époque dont nous nous étions
démarquer j'ai dix langues et fabuleux
voyage
oui parce qu'ils appartenaient à une
autre époque de dans lequel les moeurs
était un peu différente de sa 4e revenir
long quand on va revenir fabius
finalement on se rend compte que les
vacations c'est pas à moi qu'il faut la
poser c'est pas moi qui les ai avionnais
lé si tu nous regardes bien réglée
c'était un homme
bien alors vous avez peur du requin aux
sosies de ou le porte parole de ce sont
ces paroles de jasmin oui alors la vraie
question en fait que j'ai envie de vous
poser c'est comment vous vous êtes un
des meilleurs spécialistes mondiaux de
physique des fluides de géophysique de
file géochimie cosmochimie des trucs que
je crois que c'est une science que vous
avez inventé toute façon j'ai fait j'ai
eu une contribution dans cette 1re
grands noms vous êtes un grand savant ou
et enfin bon bilan mais ne soyez pas
restée intense et bien on peut être un
mauvais ministre ans avant voilà c'est
pas un conte faisaient sérieusement vous
savez bien même si vous avez du mal à
accepter les compliments vous êtes
quelqu'un de très important sur le plan
de la recherche scientifique
vous êtes un des rares qui est le
privilège de pouvoir analysé des roches
de la lune rapportés par la mission
apollo vous êtes un scientifique de haut
niveau et vos travaux ont permis la
dalle dalle ça doit être un peu vrai
allez passons l'ensemble vos travaux ont
permis l'adaptation de la terre oui
c'est vrai qu'est-ce que vous êtes allé
foot là non est ce que vous seriez pas
plus utile finalement à continuer vos
recherches scientifiques ont fait
vraiment avancer les chiens je vais vous
dire un truc un peu fou dans ce bordel
de la policiers vous dit si vous si vous
regardez le bon bilan à l'éducation
nationale ce que j'ai fait et dans la
recherche la loi sur l'innovation
l'harmonisation européenne la
déconcentration etc vous pouvez le
comparer avec tous les bilans des
ministres de l'éducation nationale qui
vont précéder et vous verrez qu'ils se
situent honorablement bien le problème
est de savoir qu'a t'il fait parce que
c'était meilleur arrive en ville après
lui c'est tout est-ce qu'il a servi ce
pays où est-ce qui s'est lui servi c'est
ça la question tôt nous reste ça compte
pas ça c'est clair que les plus serviles
pays que vous êtes servez-vous alors pas
je voyais la gamme et gris quand même
avant
hélas non hélas non vous faites quoi
pour ça je je fais coucou je fais comme
beaucoup de gens comme un changement 34e
des rideaux je vous reproche non je
prends pas mais c'est comment tu fais
comme comme comme beaucoup de gens qui
ont fait beaucoup de sport étant jeune
c'est ça s'arrête de faire du sport et
qui grossit grossit pas ce qu'il faisait
du sport avant c'est pas mal ça quand
même mais c'est bien bon nom vous dit
sérieusement vous dites page 21 de vos
clés vous dit cette phrase de votre
compère qu'as tu fait de ta vie donc
vous pensez vous utilisez aussi bien
utiliser votre vie sains et en mini
l'éducation nationale qu'en trouvant une
méthode de datation de la terre de la
planète terre et ben oui c'est ce que je
crois
[Musique]
bien vous savez qu'il faut pas bouger
par le jingle je préfère vous avertir
avant je voulais pas faire ça ne
bougeait pas pendant le jingle quoi toi
bien à saraf sarah bouge bien bien
bouger à la bienvenue vous savez bouger
claude je sais pas si vous avez entendu
ouzou tiers dans votre loge mais sarah
est un peu tout seul ah bon moi je les
mets sur lequel les italiens noah ah oui
c'est vrai
la franco l'eau bien alors on va faire
l'interview nul
[Musique]
moi
il a bougé dans tout le monde était
parfait et toi qui hérite est exemplaire
avec moi je suis obligée de l'exemple
exemplaires est ce que vous préférez
votre père ou votre mère je préfère les
deux j'ai pas de choix
c'est dur à sa non venue j'ai dit que
c'est les questions vont ça oui mais il
n'y a pas de choix
elle suit c'est une question qu'on l'a
mais j'en étais sûr est ce que vous
préférez hitler ou staline dit pas les
idiots
alors c'est le coude du clos la peste ou
le choléra ça mais je peux pas choisir
non plus c'est le c'est important vous
les mettez au même niveau
je déteste les deux voies là non parce
que c'est qu'en france il ya toujours
des gens qui vous explique que staline
c'est mieux qu hitler partez pas de ce
principe là non bien déjà pas mal vous
devez partir sur une île déserte
c'est un jeu de l'esprit un vous préféré
partir avec des tapis ou dominique
strauss kahn
alors il n'y a pas de y'a pas toi y'a
pas photo dominique strauss kahn dont
les cassettes est un ami oui j'assume
cette amitié complètement ça c'est un
bon côté vous avez les socialistes vous
c'est à dire que les mecs peuvent faire
les pires trucs vous les soutenez
toujours c'est votre côté me taire mon
ami non c'est mon ami et je sujet pas à
juger tel ou tel chose c'est mon ami
donc vous partez avec dominique strauss
kahn c'est jospin est mon ami c'est mon
ami d'accord voilà oui bien sûr il est
sympa ils vont dire plus à tirer après
se seraient ils ont du mal là pour avoir
l'air sympa là il a fait douze pages
dans gala j'aime bien comment vous
regardez comme ça
oui la chebba serge je sais pas si tu as
le regarde de claude allègre quand tu me
regardes et tu les oublies c'est comme
ça quand tu lui dis une question qui
l'emmerdé
ils réclament la haute question qu'on
vous laver les cheveux tous les combien
tous les jours
hamon presque trop bien est ce que vous
préférez un président de la république
d'extrême droite élu au suffrage
universel ou pas d'élection du tout pas
d'élection du tout vous arrêtez d'être
démocratique à un moment quand ça vous
arrange plus vous arrêter d'être
démocrate
vous me posez une question je vous
réponds d'accord ça me rappelle en
algérie quand même et je vous parle fils
a failli gagner les élections en algérie
on arrêter le processus pose vous me
posez une question je vous réponds
d'accord pour adam erne était bien est
ce qu a fait son discours mr dsk me dire
qu'ils aient bataille qui est fontaine
je connaissais bataille et fontaine je
connais un joueur de foot qui s'appelle
fonds tabac juste fontaine bien sûr que
c'est autre chose c'est rentes 58 là
dessus alors vous connaissez pas
bataille et fontaine
non vous pouvez pas me dire qu'est
bataille qu'est fontaine non sarah est
ce que vous pouvez me dire que les
batailles qui est font-elles
ce sont des comiques non ce sont des
présentations sur commis que d'une
certaine façon une campagne sans
présentateur sur tf1 y'a pas photo les
batailles qui est fontaine y en a un qui
est grand mais rien qu'un peu plus petit
un peu plus gros lequel les batailles le
cas les fontaines alors je crois que
pascal c'est le grand pascal quai
n'essayez pas de m'embrouiller et
fontaine
sa fille linda qui a redit non mais ça
c'est une question interne de a pas du
tout part de marché tous les lundis soir
catherine me dit que vous avez raison
vous savez que les batailles qui est
fontaine alors claude allègre est ce que
vous aimeriez avoir un nez
supplémentaire ni suppléments n'est
supplémentaires wind and dye
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaires j'aimerais
avoir un oeil supplémentaire derrière à
toi tu as peur de te remettre
il arrive et ministre en même temps
est-ce que vous préférez une femme qui
n'aime pas tellement faire d'amour
[ __ ] fidèles ou une femme qui adore
faire l'amour mais qui était infidèle la
deuxième bien sûr ah ouais c'est bien
cette question les nouvelles à tesla je
pense pas que l'attesterait sur allègre
bel et bien oui c'était avec
construction de questions c'est vraiment
une bonne idée
vous préférez une femme qui aime faire
l'amour et au risque qu'elle soit
infidèle
oui au risque et haut risque ouais et
vous vous préférez un garçon qui
s'éclate parce que vous pouvez espérer
si vous avez suivi un comble et qu'elles
soient afin qu'elle aime faire des
gâteaux à la merci de l'explication et
vous vous préférez un garçon qui sait
pas très bien faire l'amour mais qui est
très fidèle ou un garçon qui fait
merveilleusement l'amour un italien
génial et tout mais qui en même temps
voilà il court partout mais les italiens
sont souvent infidèles
vous reprenez votre parti même choix et
c'est que la france entière se demande
quel est votre numéro de portable ça
merci brossé avec vos travaux
[Musique]
non mais même si vous avez froid tant
pis on va pas beaucoup rire quoique
effectivement je reçois maintenant
christine angot au fil à fil sans
prétention mais mauvaise réputation
comité mais nous lui reste moi je pense
qu un je ne sais quoi
les généraux bonsoir claude allègre
grands chercheurs ex-ministre de
l'éducation nationale
sarah marshall laurent baffie alors la
tronche café regardons déjà c'est pas
bon signe non ça va là oui ça c'est
quand elle va bien à vous souriez c'est
déjà mieux
vous avez bien là je vois que vous avez
bien angot christie's d'écrivains
souffert comme au tribunal c'est congo
christian quesnot égalité née le 7
février 59 à châteauroux dans l'art de
pierre angot et rachel schwartz mère
d'un enfant les honore alors vous avez
une philosophie
c'est la philosophie de christine angot
bien alors vous aimez ça à la télé non
c'est un avantage c'est que on voit on
voit on voit les gens ouais bah déjà
réussi dans la presse dans la presse
écrite
on les voit pas il ya des gens qui les
recouvre il ya des gens qui recouvre
d'autres gens dans la presse écrite
alors qu'au moins la télé on voit ce qui
se passe quoi puis on entend vraiment
les gens parlent il avoue rencontrer
claude allègre n'aurait peut-être jamais
rencontré ah non c'est pas ça ça passe
un accord c'est sympa pour lui oui mais
pas pour moi que je trouve ça devient la
tv je trouve ça bien pour pour les gens
qui regardent
j'espère alors page 27 vous dites
d'ailleurs de votre livre dont on va
parler ce soir vous dites je ne devrait
pas passer à la télé mais moi j'aime ça
passait à la télé ça donne l'occasion de
parler de dire des trucs
j'aime bien dire des trucs à la télé
d'ailleurs vous dit pas je 37-38 avoir
vu christine boutin dans cette émission
tout le monde en parle qui disait
qu'elle faisait l'amour entre la cuisine
elle était vulgaire c'est christine
boutin qui vient ici pour dire qu'elle a
fait l'amour dans la cuisine en plus ça
fait moins de scandale que vous quand
vous avez dit chez bernard pivot vous
aimiez pas l'auteur de galina
laclavetine je trouve ça oui c'est
finalement comme si c'était habituel la
vulgarité qu'on s'habitue et à la
vulgarité alors compte habitue pas la
vérité la vérité c'est une chose qui est
plus dérangeante que la vulgarité
oui enfin ça passe pas trop alors que la
vulgarité on peut aller très très loin
ça passe toujours ce qui vous surprend
le plus
je dis ça je vais vu dans votre livre
c'est que boutin en fait elle dit
qu'elle fait l'amour avec son mari dans
la cuisine mon sens encore après tout le
fait ce qu'elle veut mais elle est quand
même avec lui depuis 31 ans et elle dit
ça fait pas longtemps que j'ai fait
l'amour dans la cuisine quand ça veut
dire que chez les boutin ça va vous
parler de votre passage dans dans votre
livre quitter la ville
on va on a parlé vous parlez de votre
passage à tout le monde en parle dans
cette émission mais c'est à dire que je
parle date où toutes sortes
vous parlez de la part de tout ce qui va
pas quoi vous êtes donc et de tout ce
qui va pas mais comment quand même dans
tout ce qui va pas comme dans la vie en
général on peut quand même passé et que
voilà
c'est pour ça que je parle de de tout le
monde en parle parce que normalement moi
je sais ce que j'ai à faire à tout le
monde en parle rien et moi
ben oui pas grand chose mais bon
et vous qui regardez vous pourrez vous
changez pas de chaîne alors on va voir
de quoi vous parlez dans votre vie
michel boujenah moment d'un mois sar le
grand-duc henri combret sais pas comment
ça c'est sur scène mais avec votre vraie
votre vrai enfant quoi celui qui a
initié sa est ce que vous êtes une mère
juive
au début oui agité un petit peu je me
suis beaucoup calmé parce que je me suis
rendu compte que chaque fois qu'il tombe
et je criais way et quand je criais
crier plus fort ouais et il pensait que
il comprenait pas pourquoi j'avais plus
mal que lui
ouais et ça lui faisait mal alors je me
suis dit que je devais cinglé 20 que
maintenant quand il tombe je fais un
grave je vais dans ma chambre je ferme
la porte à double tour et je crie tout
seul et bien être a dit mais c'est un
truc que j'ai noté c'est rigolo
il faudrait un pédiatre pour vous un
pédiatre pour votre enfant mais j'en ai
c'est comme ça que ça se passait comme
ça que ça se passe
est ce que vous êtes un père juif parce
que vous êtes une famille laïque quand
même vous est-ce que vous lui inculquer
des préceptes religieux
vous savez il a deux ans et demi alors
ça serait grave
mais vraisemblablement ce que
j'essaierai lui transmettre c'est ma
mémoire c'est l'histoire de mon peuple
1 et du sien ouais c'est c'est le mode
de pensée dans lequel j'étais élevé
c'est les traditions parce que c'est
formidable de de savoir d'où on vient
parce qu'on veut pas savoir où on va si
on fait surtout vous qui venaient d'un
pays la tunisie enfin la tunisie des non
pas des pieds noirs parce que c'est pas
des pieds noirs enfin la tunisie des
thunes
c'est une [ __ ] pays comme disait
attali en parlant de l'algérie un pays
fantôme un pays qui n'existe plus ce
pays n'existe plus que dans votre
mémoire aujourd'hui
oui mais ça ce café des délices il
n'existe plus dans votre mémoire
non il existe encore aujourd'hui sauf
qu'il a beaucoup changé oui le mais la
vérité c'est que la tunisie existe
toujours c'est un pays magnifique
c'est un pays qui ce qui a des
difficultés pour moi ma tunisia - gelé
reconstruite évidemment avec moi elle me
quittera jamais elle est là elle est ici
devant vous vous la voyez pas mais ici
je la voix d'avancé que vous transmettez
la mémoire de dea boutboul oui c'est le
nom ouais c'est mon nom ci log et ouais
c'est mon nom de guerre boutboul j'adore
ce nom football le pire c'est quand j'ai
rencontré un type qui s'appelait
vraiment beau de boules mais il m'a dit
j'en peux plus de toit alors vous
réagissez comme ans sérieusement par
rapport à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
vous parler de votre peuple que ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
tout le monde se bat vous êtes une
famille laïque je le sais votre père
était militant communiste dont vous avez
été élevé dans quoi il a déchiré sa
carte à l'époque de budapest
il a longtemps il a eu raison mais bon
en même temps c'est vrai d'une famille
laïque
comment vous réagissez aujourd'hui qu'on
voyait que chacun en face à un peu
l'histoire de got milk hounsou de god is
other side c'est à dire au nom de dieu
deux peuples comme ça s'affrontent
on voit pas très bien comment comment ça
peut s'arranger cette affaire charge
jeanne je redoute détester ariel sharon
non c'est pas le problème c'est pas le
problème il faut il faut arrêter de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu je déteste
pas ariel sharon et le problème n'est
pas là ja je redoutais cette question ce
que je pense c'est que c'est très
difficile de parler ici quand on n'est
pas là bas c'est très difficile quand on
est loin quand ariel sharon va sur
l'esplanade des mosquées
trois jours avant il y avait un attentat
y ait eu des morts on n'en parle pas
d'accord quand je vois des enfants en
première ligne avec derrière eux des
palestiniens armés et devant eux
dernière mais et que j'aurai les enfants
au milieu avec les pierres jeudi qui
sont les parents de ces enfants qui ont
9 10 ans pour qui les laisse sortir
comment un père peut laisser son fils de
neuf ou dix ans sortir pour jeter des
pierres alors qui sait ce qu'ils
risquent le soldat qui en face il a 18
ans qu'est ce que voulez qu'il fasse
vous croyez qu'il va pas porté toute sa
vie la mort de l'enfant voudrait que
toute sa vie va pas le regretter
c'est trop simple ce qui se passe en
france aujourd'hui et la désinformation
qui a eu est extraordinaire
là les idées je dire informer nous c'est
ya pas longtemps il ya eu 3 3 il serait
l'un qui ont été lynchées lyncher ça
veut dire c'est pas je me bats avec toi
et je te tue ça veut dire je te prends
je tâte h et je te pend c'est pas la
même chose il faut les jeux ce que je
ressens aujourd'hui par rapport à ce qui
se passe en france sur les synagogues
qui ont été brûlés sur toute la
résurgence de cette violence qui vient
en france je pense que la presse et les
médias russes
de responsabilité vous avez un pouvoir
un pouvoir qui est dangereux qu'il faut
manipuler avec beaucoup de délicatesse
et beaucoup d'intelligence
je crois qu'il ya une légitimité il ya
quelque chose qui a légitimé cette
violence chez les jeunes ici en france
qui est illogique qui est folle on se
bat pour la paix il faut arrêter de
raconter les choses comme celles comme
ça c'est ça qui me fait le plus mal
c'est ça qui me qui me rend qui me
révolte c'est que je crois pas il ya
bien beaucoup de victimes dans cette
histoire
chez les palestiniens et celle isréliens
faut pas l'oublier quand je vois les
guignols de l'info qui ouvre le yom
kippour avec un soldat israélien avec
une mitraillette qui tirent sur des
enfants dans les marionnettes des
guignols et qui dit pardon pardon je
trouve ça mais honteux je trouve ça
monstrueux de faire ça je suis et
pourtant
gaccio et et légendes et guînes des
guignols j'ai longtemps dit que je les
aimais beaucoup mais ça je peux pas
accepter c'est monstrueux je perdais
régional faisait rire avec ça non mais
vous allez c'est faux oui et c'est faux
ya pas un soldat israélien
quand hussein de jordanie est mort le
roi de jordanie
personne n'a dit personne n'a rappelé
tout le monde a dit oui comme il était
gentil personne n'a dit qu en une
semaine il en a tué dix mille des
palestiniens ces petits miroirs bon
quand il a eu un problème avec eux mais
s'ils lisent rien voulait macrez
massacrer les palestiniens croient qu'il
ne ferait pas voudrait qu'ils ont pas
les moyens
vous croyez que les gosses de 18 ans ils
sont contents d'être là où il en faisait
pas les indiens qu'ils ont des gosses en
face d'eux quand j'ai vu un palestinien
la télé il ya deux jours qui a perdu un
fils ça me fait de la peine de voir un
homme perdre son fils créé moyen à 20
enfants
je sais ce que c'est il qu'est ce qu'il
a dit là dijon encore quatre à sacrifier
jeunes encore 4 il n'a pas dit je vais
aller me battre mois il a dit j'ai
encore quatre à sacrifier vous êtes
excusez moi je vais arrêter là on en
attendait c'est pas une question d'être
long c'est que il ya quelques il ya
quelques jeux
pour quelques semaines vous étiez
beaucoup moins engagez vous disiez
sharon a eu tort une pierre en parlant
des gt m'a lancé une pierre vaut-elle la
vie d'un enfant dont vous étiez beaucoup
plus distanciée et beaucoup moins engagé
mais tous avaient choisi vous êtes on
vous trouve là ce que je veux c'est
naturel je voulais jouer mais il
rentrait pas dans leurs projets vous
êtes beaucoup plus métier je me suis
engagé je me suis fait avoir je n'avais
pas les bonnes informations j'étais en
pleine répétition mon spectacle les
événements étaient pas ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui moi je veux qu'on
rééquilibre les choses et je veux qu'on
se bat pour la paix parce que c'est pas
ce que je voudrais rendre une éloge au
ravin sitruk qui a qui a fait qui a
parlé le jour de yom kippour à la
synagogue de la victoire et qui a dit en
gros qu'on soit un enfant de palestine
d'israël ou d'ailleurs tout le monde
doit vivre dans la paix parce que tous
les enfants qui sont élevées dans la
violence qui connaissent que la violence
peuvent pas peuvent pas vivre dans la
paix et aimer son prochain respecter le
prochain et ça je trouve ça essentiel
pour les valeurs humaines et je pense
que c'est la raison
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que la
situation
si on veut la dépasser il faut plus que
c'est les deux les deux parties soient
là à se partager des territoires des
choses comme ça il faut leur donner un
espoir et je pense que l'espoir c'est de
faire ce qui a été fait en europe de
proposer de faire un marché commun du
moyen-orient d'ordonner une dans lequel
ils pourront travailler ensemble chacun
aura quelques le rêve le rêve je vais
vous dire que je pense qu'il ya une
occasion jourd'hui attendait le rêve
cible c'est que ça se passe les
allemands les français sont fait trois
guerres ils sont ils perçus un gérant à
domicile de l'année site ou de soirée
mais ça s'est arrangé aujourd'hui nommé
les allemands à ce qu'il ya des gens n'y
avait pas de problème religieux y avec
le nationalisme
aujourd'hui je veux dans le moyen-orient
il ya le nationaliser mais juste à
religion oui mais je pense que c'est ça
le problème je pense que on est dans une
circonstance au moyen-orient en jordanie
n'a changé on a on a il ya un jeune roi
en syrie un nouveau dirigeant il ya eu
deux baraques et arafat quoi qu'on dise
se parle il ya un chef d'état en egypte
pied qui est sage il faut essayer de
fabriquer quelque chose de positif parce
que à partir du moment où ils verront
que le dépassement c'est pour construire
quelque chose dans leur intérêt dans le
dans pour développer le commerce la
culture excellent monde est d'accord
avec ça que de maisons mais je le
considère michel r est ce qu'il dit ça
je dis pas le contraire mais passe très
bien
bien qu'ils aient des reportages en
viens sur ce qui se passe entre les
juifs et les palestiniens depuis depuis
les accords d'oslo où les passeurs le
nombre de contacts
le nombre de constructions qui ensemble
là il ya un projet de télévision
il ya des îles vous pouvez pas savoir
tous les contacts plan économique sur le
plan agricole qui entre les juifs et les
israéliens et les palestiniens
donc les choses avancer la paix les
passions s il faut pas dire que
l'absolument ans il faut jamais dire
qu'en personnes disent à chaque camp est
quand même victime de ces intégristes
étaient des pierres en israël des partis
religieux orthodoxes excusez-moi
d'extrême droite qui interdisent la paix
parce que c'est bien beau de critiquer
le pen en français oui ma raison
simplement en israël il ya des
intégrismes et son pire et il ya des du
côté du ramasse il ya aussi des aux
intégrismes et on les critique donc
c'est en ça que les politiques on s'y
met on écrit seulement comme l'allemagne
et la france n'est pas toi une religion
de leur semaine entre jeu thierry au
sommet m pour ça j'ai pas comme je
n'avais pas de souvenirs vous n'avez pas
de souvenirs parce que vous êtes
probablement trop jeune mais quand
général de gaulle oui pince mais quand
général de gaulle a décidé de tendre la
main à delaware vous avez eu en france
un tollé d'un certain nombre de gens et
moi j'ai su d'une famille de résistants
et je peux vous dire que c'était pas
c'était pas apprécier pleinement
c'était la même chose mais il ya eu ce
courage de dépasser cette chose là et
moi je vais vous dire je crois bien
lyonnais revient aujourd'hui on y sera
je crois de la mayenne orient oui mais
je pense que c'est là que l'europe peut
donner est un exemple de ce point de vue
maison quel pourrait être le lieu où on
pourrait discuter de ça on à la
présidence française
on peut proposer quelque chose mais
proposons quelque chose de positif ne
faisons pas comme avec la yougoslavie ou
maintenant on invite les serbes
et si avant qu'ils se battront les avait
invités et si avant déclare yougoslavie
à a démarré on leur avait proposé
quelque chose avec l'europe
peut-être qu'on n'aurait pas eu ce bain
de sang je pense que il faut dépasser
tant qu'on restera dans des problèmes de
partage de forcément chacun poussera
dans son pays
dans les enclaves multipliez ça
s'arrangera pas on ne fera pas oui mais
pas assez d'expérience de géopolitique
comme monsieur allègre pour porter ce
genre d' analyse tout ce que je sais
c'est que depuis que j'ai 15 ou 16 ans
je milite pour la paix c'est vrai que
que je me suis battue que ça pas
toujours été facile en france parce que
c'est pas toujours facile de faire en
tant que cette voie là que je continue à
penser que la paix n'est pas morte que
j'ai envie d'entendre parler de la paix
que j'ai envie d'entendre parler d'eux
dans des discours comme ça et que j'en
ai marre d'entendre des gens qui me
disent mais arrêtez d'être utopiste des
gens à qui je réponds que c'est avec les
utopies qu'on construit l'avenir bien
fait avec les utopies qu'on change le
monde et c'est avec les rêves qu'on
avance dans la question sur le sujet
il n'aurait pas été en finale
ouais d'année si ça doit arriver vous
avez raison
dernière question sur le sujet ce que
vous pensez que les médias français
désinforme oui profit des palestiniens
oui je pense qu'il ya un problème très
pervers qui est déchirée entre le plus
bleu le plaisir malsain de l'information
qui vend et qui fait de l'audience et
qui touche les gens sans se rendre
compte des conséquences du pouvoir que
les médias ont sur l'opinion publique et
je pense qu'il ya une mauvaise souvent
une mauvaise analyse politique
tout simplement parce que ils sont mal
informés de ce qui se passe là bas ils
ont pas les bonnes informations
voilà ce que je pense moi ce que je
crois qui est que michel boujenah a
commencé par dire une chose qui est très
vrai dans un dans un pays tension comme
ça il faut faire très attention que
quand quand des choses se déclenchent de
pas à laisser c'est un peu comme dans
une cour de récréation à qui la faute
tandis qu là c'est très difficile donc
il faut tenir un équilibre très stricte
entre les deux et dire de toute manière
il faut ramener la paix il faut il faut
lutter pour la paix et de faire très
attention d'avoir aucun dérapage ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre
c'est essentiel c'est pas qu'on aime
l'un ou l'autre mais c'est essentiel si
on veut avancer si on commence l'analyse
parce qu'on sait pas il se produit un
incident mais parfois cet incident il
répond un autre incident on ne connaît
pas assez vrai c'est très ambitieux
c'est très stressant si c'est très
sensible prêterait ses traits sens que
je vous propose maintenant je suis
désolé un vote en application le je suis
un humoriste
non non attendez l'énorme marée j'adore
négociations
je dois faire le job charme de cette
émission le charme de cette émission
c'est qu'on peut à la fois parler de
choses très sérieuses et puis dire des
fois des grosses conneries alors on va
on va passer maintenant à quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus gai oui vous êtes
prêts pour blind test claude tout le
monde vous attend sur le blind test la
musique
et maintenant j'appelle d'abord mi temps
nous à
ça fait quatre semaines ya quatre
semaines qui plombe
star de cette émission est face à lui ce
soir puisque on écoute parti pour
changer se sortir ici on parle peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
robin et mickaël la bonne idée donc
c'est le prof
corty c'est très sympa abbassi attend
alors ce que je dois dire aussi pour
complètement dédouaner michael sait que
le look qu'il a c'est pas qui se la pète
c'est moi qui lui demandent de
s'habiller comme ça je dis ça pour tous
les emails que j'ai d'ailleurs j'ai un
email de caroline qui le dit et qui nous
parle avouent et qui dit un authentique
génie se doit de résister aux caprices
du despotisme
même s'il est éclairée ça c'est moi
remettez anciennes lunettes mon frère
d'accord moi je dis non
voilà il y avait un lien qui dit que tes
cheveux de la semaine dernière était pas
terrible il était jaune façon urines de
chat de gouttière et alors il ya c'est
quoi un qui me dit que vous êtes
veilleur de nuit dans un hôtel et silva
me dis que c'est pas dans domicile
conjugal qu'antoine doinel et veilleur
de nuit mais c'est dans baisers volés il
dit y aller fumer je réponds non asseoir
la voilà alors maintenant nous sommes là
une thèse spécial mauvais garçons en
hommage à corti merci vous avez sens
commun avec bernard tapie c'est d'être
un mauvais garçon la politique là de la
politique mais du pire la différence et
qu'allègre vous tolère sur le bureau sur
le plateau c'est parce qu'on l'aimé bien
quand vous êtes pris intention là c'est
très très chaud donc je rappelle l'enjeu
michael a battu tout le monde depuis
quatre semaines s'il gagne ce soit il
revient la semaine prochaine et cissé
corti qui gagne ça peut être quelqu'un
d'autre aussi bien sur la personne qui
n'est pas juste c'est vraiment rien
d'autre
si personne contrairement à la wii c'est
ça mon garçon demanda demanda alors à
combien d'équipés il avait contre lui à
sydney avant d'arriver en personne
contre toi et tu n'as plus qu'une
déjà je rappelle je rappelle dans qu'il
s'agit du blind thèse mauvais garçon
tout le monde est prêt et donc le on va
voir tout de suite si didier veut bien
envoyé la première musique c'est tout
média l'intervalle joe dassin bien
les pires cas des emprunts non parce que
qu'elle est olivier linda hardy leurs
filets les réponses là je suis sûr que
ma femme les a pas fait d accord ça
c'est clair
est-ce qu'on va maintenant re mais juge
qu en dites quoi t'as pas eu brésil ah
ça vous avez reconnu
c'est son métier à l'éval tagada
attention là c'est très très sérieux je
sens là donc qu'est-ce qui a écrit sur
cette ardoise parce que mes montres
montre-moi la rémoise qu'est-ce qui a
écrit je suis partagé les points
d'accord approche toi ameline parce que
si tu veux partir pendant dix ans avant
tu disais corti le score est là non mais
il n'arrive plus à suivre
il me manque les pensionnats alors aussi
chanson numéro 2 la bourse tomber val di
corti 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et oui mon papa moi c'est un gangster
c'est un peu ce que pourrait dire votre
fils une certaine façon oui domtar oui
docteur stomy bugzy donc oui c'est là je
suis désolé c'est un peu largué claude
mais en même temps est en même temps là
on atteint des sommets la cible et
l'accès j'avais vu à la première note
qu'ils reconnaissent
il reconnaît surtout pour l'instant je
ne suis pas dans mon hall alors si
mickaël père sera un drame
il vous rendez pas compte bon tout le
monde est bien concentré sarah sicard
tigana c'est gentil mais aussi n'avoir
pas pour moi il a marqué deux points
attention sans son numéro trois monnaies
moi je suis désolé il ya là vraiment je
pense que la bonne façon de vérifier
effectivement gantin petites faiblesses
michael c'était corti la bonne façon de
vivre et mickaël attention va voir on
n'est qu'à la chanson numéro trois
chansons numéro quatre billets du temps
[Musique]
koweit
y aller allègre est émise éducation
nationale mais là il n'a jamais vu ça
non mes parents étaient ainsi ses
parents il a mal lu c'est celui qui a
mal tourné hier je voulais transmettre
un message c'est il disait que c'est
dommage qu'il soit parti
ah ah oui bravo vos parents fait tes
parents on sait que c'est dommage que
beaucoup de profs ya aussi des preuves
de mes enfants il dit c'est ouais bah
oui oui
maintenant il va se lancer dans
l'adaptation de la terre de nouveaux
champs son numéro 5
myspace les messieurs 1
j'ai dit non non non ça fou maintenant
on a maintenant on a mis au point un
système de filmage qui fait serge
chanson numéro 5
illac korstine quand il a fait en pop up
mai
m
oh
hockey québec
attention on est usé mes garçons sans
son numéro 6 d'acer la bande à volonté
si son boulot de corte ils font des
signes il veut le tenir et comme une
merde non c'est pas vrai c'est là c'est
pas vrai du tout c'est ça l'art et le
nickel les emails en disant que j'ai
tout fait pour virer michael c'est pas
vrai les chansons sont choisis les corti
corti battant perdre contre corti c'est
comme perdre contre la nba d'accord ok
mais là je bataille m'a dit qu'on serait
là tu seras médaille d'argent à bas
niveau chanson numéro 7
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sochaux annoncé
non c'est perdre dans ça compte pas il a
mis la révélation avons répondu ouais
c'est bien chez didier ton chèque est à
la compta bon ce point marche pas
chanson numéro 8
les portes du pénitencier johnny
hallyday le pénitencier corti
chanson numéro 9 je veux l'interprète
[Musique]
à l'honneur oui mais ça je mange les as
nancy
l'éclatant les quarts d'heure
chanson numéro 10 gazeau d'agde william
klein exact en brigitte bardot et serge
gainsbourg catherine quel est le score 6
2 ben philippe ravaux fils est sorti à
gagner la nuit
mika je suis désolé vous avez tenu
quatre semaines c'est un cinquième
c'était la cinquième aujourd'hui je suis
soulagé non non non non non non non j'ai
pas 2 g par deux partis pris et j'ai dit
qu'à un moment effectivement plutôt que
s'affronter excusez moi de vous le dire
à tous les pilotes s'affronter à vous il
fallait des lycéens répondent à un vrai
champion il est rapidement interpellé
franchement non pas plus que vous non
c'est pas possible tu vas me dire tu
j'ai pris un bon équilibre venue la
semaine prochaine avec le géant j'ai
maintenant un peu corsé jeu que je
préfère à ça avec des boules quiès
voilà c'était tout le monde en parle
michel boujenah moment d'un mois au
palais des congrès jusqu'au 31 décembre
caunègre toute vérité est bonne à dire
chez fayard robert laffont christine
angot quitté la ville après quitté le
plateau chez stock
bernard tapie
quitter le plateau aussi rien à cacher
tous les dimanche à 19h20 sur rtl9 et
puis bolt y d'un nid de coucou en
tournée en france l'ancien demain soir
contre antibes avec son club de
villeurbanne salon marshall à bientôt
sur les écrans
certains leur avis ni prendre son cours
normal fuit bonsoir menace était tout
blanc par l'émission pas comme les
autres rendez-vous dans quinze jours
c'est à dire le 28 octobre
[Musique]
non
des bramais
oui
il dit
yu
baby
jusqu'où
tu as
l'espagnol
[Musique]
tu sais
c'est mieux
ap
moi que moi
non
[Musique]